c'est le pire épisode de smog depuis
plus de trois ans en inde dans la
capitale le taux de particules fines
dépasse le maximum sur cette échelle de
la qualité de l'air à ce niveau passé
une journée à new delhi équivaut à fumer
un paquet de cigarettes l'air est un pur
nauséabond difficile à respirer à tel
point que les autorités ont fermé les
écoles et suspendu les chantiers de
construction
les gens présentent des problèmes
respiratoires explique cette infirmière
ils ont des irritations aux yeux et à la
peau
certains développent des maladies
cardiaques ou de l'asthme les principaux
responsables de cette pollution sont les
émissions industrielles et les feux
allumés par les agriculteurs qui
défriche à l'aide de la technique du
brûlis dans les états voisins
pendant ce temps les autorités
réglemente le trafic automobile les
véhicules dont la plaque
d'immatriculation se termine par un
chiffre perd son permis une journée sur
deux l'autre étant réservé aux chiffres
impairs cette mesure permet de réduire
près de quatre millions de véhicules par
jour dans la capitale mais elle est
jugée inefficace
irina ce n'est pas assez cette
manifestante
nous voulons des changements viable sur
du long terme selon l'organisation des
nations unies treize des vingt villes
les plus polluées dans le monde
actuellement sont en inde
ici julier mon radio canada montréal